calcium Imaging is a super useful tool
used by all neuroscientists to monitor
activity from many neurons and this
could be recorded simultaneously in real
time
in fact the neuronal activity can be
monitored from a behaving animal that's
why neurosbiologist loves it
so it always requires a calcium
sensitive dye or a genetically encoded
calcium sensor like gcamp
so gcam can report the neuronal activity
so when there is a calcium change this
diode would fluoresce
and there is a Formula called Delta F by
F relative change in fluorescence with
respect to the Baseline this would give
us an idea about the overall neuronal
activity
but there are several disadvantages of
the gcam the temporal resolution is
sometimes not high enough to delineate
fast spiking events watch the full video
to know more